welcome to my brand-new dork corner I
like this corner so if any of my newer
viewers are unfamiliar with this I have
a segment on my channel that I do from
time to time and I refer to it as an
overlooked movie review and what that
means is it's a film that I think is
really good or that is underrated or
that just didn't make a lot of money the
box office it's a way for me to talk
about a movie that isn't like the big
movie of the week you know maybe this
one went by without you noticing it
maybe it slipped under the rug a little
bit perhaps it deserves your attention I
put a playlist on my home channel of all
of my overlooked reviews I've done so
far if you want to go to my channel page
you can see that playlist and see the
other reviews I've done let's talk about
Cowboy Bebop the movie cowboy bebop the
movie is possibly in my opinion the
greatest anime film ever made there's a
lot of different animes that I really
like films like Akira or ghost in the
shell' those are animated films that
change the way America viewed cartoons
because cartoons in America means
something very different than it means
over in Japan see in Japan there's this
great great use of animation for realism
for mature adult things and I'm not
talking about hentai I'm talking about
you know mature films in the other sense
in America where cartoons are generally
looked at as entertainment to please
young people in Japan it's something
that is for everyone and I really like
that about Japan and the anime they use
there so not only am i a fan of this
film but I am also a fan of the TV show
this is actually my favorite anime if
you have not seen Cowboy Bebop I
strongly suggest it if you're not a fan
of anime I strongly suggest it anyway
because this is the type of anime that
you can start watching and just
appreciate for its artistic value alone
the music and it is incredible and this
transfers over to the film so let's talk
a little bit about the plot of this
series essentially the show takes place
in the future where a lot of people have
migrated away from Earth and are now
living in space or on Mars or other
places around the galaxy
[Music]
this show centers on a group of bounty
hunters and these guys go around looking
for bounty heads but they're generally
always poor and in need of money and
starving and the show has just as much
humor as it has intense drama and
incredible action the main character's
name is spike and spike Spiegel is this
guy who has a serious past with his old
syndicate that he used to be a part of
and in this movie this group of bounty
hunters encounter this really evil guy
named Vincent this guy is dead set on
this sort of chemical warfare some
things were done to him in the past that
have really ruined him and he wants to
set that loose on mankind and the bounty
hunters are trying not only to catch him
because there's a humongous bounty head
on him like an absurd amount of money
that would set them all for life but
they also want to save mankind now it's
impossible for me to review the cowboy
bebop film or the series without talking
about its style it is incredible there
are a few feature-length films with the
amount of style that that show in this
movie have Yoko Kanno the composer is an
absolute genius I would love to be able
to meet her some day even if she can't
speak English I'm not sure if she can
I'd probably swap to and be like hello
your music is amazing it's you'd be like
she uses old-time jazz combined with
contemporary rock combined with heavy
metal there like there literally is no
genre that you can pinpoint in her music
and her music combined with this film
and this series created a whole genre
around itself and that honestly is what
cowboy bebop is about it is its own
thing it's its own genre you can't
identify it alongside anything else
[Music]
as the film progresses and as the
characters try harder and harder to
catch this guy Vincent they run into
each other a few times they have a few
battles it's all extremely riveting the
way the film looks the way the film
sounds there is no other animated film
like this you don't have to have seen
the series to enjoy this film in fact
this film is completely standalone from
this series it takes place in the middle
of a few episodes towards the latter
half of the show if you are interested
in starting out with anime if you've
never watched anime if you think anime
is stupid or boring I implore you please
check out this show Cowboy Bebop but
also check out this movie first this
would be a great way to get you into the
show and it's completely standalone from
the show and you can experience it for
the first time if you have not seen any
anime extra only suggest checking out a
few some of my favorites are of course
Dragonball Z I grew up with Dragon Ball
Z Trigon is excellent outlaw star ghost
in the shell' stand alone complex other
anime films that are good are Princess
Mononoke spirited away my neighbor
totoro really honestly anything directed
by Hayao Miyazaki is worth your time but
this is kind of a combined thing it's an
anime er view but it's also an
overlooked movie review this is a movie
that made less than a million dollars at
the American box office it's a film that
really only anime fans are fans of
Cowboy Bebop probably sought out if you
are not a fan of Cowboy Bebop if you've
never seen it if you're not a fan of
anime if you don't watch it I strongly
suggest checking this film out and
letting me know what you thought I'm
gonna give Cowboy Bebop the movie or as
it's called in Japan Cowboy Bebop
knocking on heaven's door and eh thanks
a lot for watching guys and as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes do a cowboy what
did you mean why are you just a humble
bounty hunter man
[Music]